um good evening everybody welcome to
this meeting um
of the public protection subcommittee
welcome to
committee members this evening we've got
a couple of items
on our agenda today to look at in policy
terms
we start we'll just note attendances
that we've got apologies from
councillors
churchill bunting and thomas
everyone else is in attendance this
evening there's no substitutes
and then just um to receive the minutes
of the meeting held on the 25th of june
if somebody can just
um their correct record
correct record thank you
so if we just move on to item three
which is the kovid 19
licensing service team plan that i think
is going to be taken by our licensing
manager jerome boyle
thanks chair uh members of the summer
committee and the report before you
today is
um the latest proposals in our phased
approach to
um delivering the licensing service
since lockdown um
and we're seeking approval to the three
proposals
firstly um the report refers to the
decision
of the subcommittee at the beginning of
the pandemic to suspend
all stages of the new driver application
process
this was obviously because we couldn't
safely facilitate the knowledge test and
induction course
which are normally classroom based so we
continue to work
on developing a remote solution to that
but
until that's in place and whilst the
social discipline rules remain
we're asking that the suspension of the
new driver application process continue
um until at least the end of this year
when it will be reviewed again so the
hope is that we will draft another
report
for you to consider in december which
will outline
our proposals for the new year and
secondly
the report proposes that the licensing
reception desk remains
closed with licensing staff continuing
to work
from home this is obviously in
accordance with the directive from the
council
that we work from home where possible um
and officers are only visiting the town
hall
to produce hard copy licenses badges and
plates at the moment
and finally the third proposal is that
those vehicles
are due a vehicle check on or after the
30th of september
and this includes all those vehicles
whose vehicle check due dates were
extended
from april may and june that we now ask
them to produce
have their vehicle inspected and produce
an mlt certificate
and further that certificate is a clear
pass with no advisories and that's
in line with our historically high
vehicle standard requirements
so those are the the matters for
consideration and have to answer any
questions members
may have but i'd like to recommend the
proposals to the subcommittee
is there any members of the committee
that's got any questions at all
at this stage councillor taylor and then
councillor welton
thank you joanne um so if there
are no new drive for tests does that
mean no new drivers can apply and
commence work as a trafford registered
driver then and over this time
well when we um when we
went into lockdown we had around about
700 um drivers who were in the process
applicants sorry you were in the process
right um
we had historically had a very large
waiting list and we had managed to get
to the point that we'd invited everybody
on that list to start the process we
just
we just sent the last email out to
everybody
and people were starting to um um
say yes i want to book on to a test or
they were going through to the next
stage which was the induction course
so we had to halt all that so we have in
in the process around about 700
applications right
right so um to open it
up to any new one yeah actually
registering their interest would
obviously
um continue to add this they can still
register their interest
so that will probably start to grow as
well
uh people we've not even contacted yet
they've just registered with their
interest
um but yes fundamentally we can't we're
saying we're not we don't want to
process any um
[Music]
drivers at the moment because we can't
facilitate
a safe environment for um
for those knowledge tests and induction
courses which
mainly that's what most people are
waiting for and
we can't use it's difficult to use the
town hall facilities
yeah for um the testing we could
possibly use one or two of the rooms but
you'd have to have
a very small number yeah yeah
we'd still need to have the test we
think um
online yes in the past it would have
been um
a written test and they where they've
done it
previously where did they used to do it
they used to do we had
an arrangement with um ua 92
we just entered an arrangement with them
and we were using the
classroom facilities yeah which was
working out really really well we guess
we could do quite a number of people
would do about um
50 uh at a session so we were we were
getting through
the candidates really really quickly
yeah and
we not really got that facility at the
moment so we're 92 aren't offering that
um the only option would be to use town
hall facilities and as
as i say um it's limited space so they
don't
really want people to come coming into
the town hall building at the moment
no so we continue to um
try and develop an online solution so
um that we could perhaps offer that but
we really want it in
kind of you know test
situations
necessarily people doing it from their
homes yes
um but that's the problem is actually
finding a location
where we can have a number of people
because it wouldn't be worth it
otherwise
or whatever yeah yeah we're not going to
get through the numbers
we're waiting um yeah so the hope is if
we if we can
you know get something sooner than that
we will obviously bring it back to the
committee for
their approval but um
you just can't facilitate them okay
thank you
thank you i think somebody just wanted
to ask a question didn't they as well
councillor welton
uh i just wanted to ask what other
authorities uh uh
uh where they're up to on this
uh are wolverhampton still licensing
taxi drivers and can taxi drivers just
go there
um i don't know i can't honestly say um
i know what mother hampton are doing but
i think a lot of theirs was online
already
um and i don't think you have to do a
knowledge test in wolverhampton
um so they're all theirs is online
anyway so you could
you cannot apply um
to them i don't think they've ever
stopped actually processing applications
in wolverhampton
um so yes there is that issue that other
authorities um
[Music]
perhaps have the facilities already to
process applications
when people we've had to over the last
six months
set up a system where we can work from
home
and process applications electronically
which
we weren't in a position to do before
but other authorities already had that
facility so i think those who were
desperate to get into the
trade may well have sourced another
authority
where they could do that and have we
been
and are we talking to other authorities
about
best practice in terms of online
registration and
shortly about the greater manchester
minimum standards um
which uh we've been working on with all
the other
um lasting uh authorities in greater
manchester
um and that is to look at consistent
ways of
processing policies and so on
um so yes we have we do discuss
um processes and benchmarking
um some authorities um
are still like ourselves developing
online
approaches but it has fought this
situation has forced local authorities
to look at that and i think that is
going to be the way forward for
for for everybody everybody will will be
looking to do
online applications i think manchester
for instance they already had that
facility
if you wanted to apply you did it online
um
and i think more and more authorities of
my colleagues um
have been setting up those systems in
greater manchester so we will be
uh there will be lots of authorities
doing the same thing
and the tr you know people who want to
get into the trade will have the choice
um of um going to another greater mesh
authority possibly if
if they're having to wait um to to apply
to trafford
um but hopefully it you know we will be
in a position
in the new year to start it and to start
the intention would be to
do it as quickly as possible so do as
many tests as we can
in a short period of time so we can get
through those
numbers as quickly as possible so i'll
be looking at resources
and how we can resource that okay thank
you very much
have we got any other questions at all
yes sure can i use it yeah
yeah thank you uh just following on for
the previous uh
uh one uh the in terms of being able to
test
people are we not able to use any other
facilities other than the town hall
building you know i mean
like sale west community center these
others you know where
you could perhaps have
the tests um
it just seems that you know you've got
schools back you know your educational
establishments and
other councils doing it why we seem to
be
incapable of doing it at this stage you
know i think well as i said the other
issue would be for us
we are still developing it as an online
test so we haven't got um
a working test an online test
so even if we were to be able to um
you know agree an arrangement with a
school or a college or a
university again um
what we want to do is to cut down on
paper
[Music]
so you effectively don't want to you're
not the intention isn't there to do
any physical testing and you know in any
establishment or anything though
because if we're not wanting to do paper
tests we want to move towards a digital
solution
and that's and that unfortunately that
isn't as
straightforward as we um anticipated
so we're looking at various providers of
that
um whether we can develop it in-house so
we're talking to our it team
um so obviously um i rit team have been
very busy um recently so not been able
to give us as much time as we'd hoped um
but um i think what we would like to do
is try and keep it in-house if we can
and use our own you know our old team
to to develop and obviously there will
be implications
in terms of security and whether whether
you know people duplicating or
substituting for
people online you know yeah so we
wouldn't want to be doing it like you
know saying that you
you do the test in your in your own home
we would want to have
somewhere where it could be supervised
but um
right to cut down on handling paper and
so on and guess
so that it could be automated in it to a
certain extent i think that that's what
i thought that was better because i mean
i wasn't quite sure what what you meant
by when online whether just people doing
it from
at home just being given some kind of
code which anybody else could use
perhaps you know
i think i've done i've done those kind
of tests where uh
you know academic ones where you go into
an establishment you go into a cubicle
and yeah you do the test online and you
get you know like the code
and and you've vetted in so to speak so
yeah i understand that no
we want the two things have to go are in
tandem and
we've got to be supervised to a certain
extent
so that we can verify the person who's
there
that that's the person who has applied
and
we've done the necessary checks and um
but um it's actually kind of more
automated
and we're not handling lots of paper and
it's and it's all recorded
um in one central place so um
and then we can change it as um if we
have to you know so that we can
uh change up the the test itself um
easily
so we've got lots of options of test
papers as it were
um so yeah so we're still working on
that and we hope to
have something uh we might try and do a
trial
in december so that we can come back and
let you know
you know um that we've got something
that that works in practice
okay good any other questions at all on
this paper
at this stage no joanna i've just got
one
have you got any intelligence at all
about existing trade and about
how it's our existing um the hackney and
taxi drivers are getting on in terms of
how much work they're getting and
business and and
the top of the protection of the of the
current trade
i've got nothing at the moment um but
when we're going to talk about the the
next report
um the consultation on the minimum
licensing standards
which is going is proposed to go out in
october
um ask a lot of questions um
of of the existing trade about the
impact
of kobe 19 on the industry
and obviously that's going to feed into
what um
what we want to achieve in gm around
the minimum standards and the clean air
plan as well
so hopefully we will be getting um
analysis of all those um questions
and all that feedback um after the
consultation
um i've not really had anything um
from the trade at the moment that i
could could say was indicative of
how they're faring they're fine well if
we've no other questions then we
can um we can take those recommendations
and therefore we approve
those three parts of the thing around
the suspension
of new driver applications until the
31st of december and reviewed
at that stage and then same around
keeping the license and reception desk
closed and
working at home and getting somebody in
as when we need to do that
and the same with the mot's we can
approve that as well
so thank you for that report um and then
just moving on to item four on the
agenda
there's also um just an update on the
greater manchester minimum standards
and the traffic and the traffic of
hackney carriage and private license and
private hire license and policy for
joanna
back to you thanks chad um the
subcommittee may recall
that it considered a report on the 20th
of june
last year which saw agreement to um
traffic council taking
part in the greater manchester minimum
standards consultation
um it also considered a request to
consult
on trafford's own happy carriage and
private higher policy
the subcommittee approved that request
and the consultations were due to start
on the 16th of august
2019 but unfortunately
the consultation didn't go ahead um
due to a delay in the decision and on
the funding support proposals
for those who would be impacted by the
proposals
but now it's proposed that the
consultation will take part
place from early october um this year
for a period of eight weeks
um just as a brief refresher for the
members
the 10 greater manchester authorities
have been um
working together to develop this set of
common minimum licensing standards
known as the mls um and that's in
respect of
the taxi and private hire licensing
regimes um what we're posing is a set of
minimum standards developed to create
this kind of single
vision for um drivers
operators and vehicles in the future
which we hope will also support
um the clean air plan
um and this also whilst allowing each
authority to exceed
these minimums where they consider it's
appropriate
so in trafford we've reviewed all our
current taxi policies
and brought them all together into one
document this includes the proposals
in the mls so
trafford's licensing policy is
intrinsically linked
to the mls and it's proposed that we do
like a separate
eight-week consultation on our own taxi
policy
which will start from the beginning of
october in parallel
with the consultation on the clean air
plan and
the gm minimum licensing standards so
our consultation document will be
published on the council's website
promoted by a social media and
various other and there'll be a link
on that web page to the mls consultation
which is being hosted on the um
tfgm transport for greater manchester
website in terms of the contents of the
consultation documents um
members may remember that my director
adrian fisher
he hosted a presentation for councils a
few weeks ago
which explained the proposals in more
detail i'm happy to send that to
members again if they haven't already
seen it
um but this report is kind of just for
noting and
i'm happy to answer any questions the
members may have
um if any about the proposals and the
time scales
thank you john just for those of you
that weren't on the committee
last year there is a little bit of an
anomaly here because obviously we're
even this is nate and we're moving we
were asked last year to approve the
consultation
but without seeing the document that was
being consulted on and there was a
little bit of tune and throwing that how
can we do that
but there was a wish for that
information not to get into the public
domain before the consultation
started so we get that it's a bit of a
strange ask
of and actually we approved that last
year we're not asking you to reapprove
that we just
need to note it but we do understand
that that is still a little bit of an
anomaly that we're asking
to approve something that you're not
seeing it's we understand that's
a little bit out of the ordinary duran
just by opening the questions can i just
ask one
question we just put it 2.1
uh the consultation didn't go ahead in
august 19 due to a delay in the decision
on the funding support proposals
can you just explain to the committee
where that's up to is that funding being
agreed now is that why the
consultation's going ahead or is there
still
no we're still waiting i think we're
still
waiting for a funding decision uh
on a number of elements including
the funding ask for hackney carriage
vehicle owners
so i think we we have asked the
government for funding of 10.2
million perhaps they had a carriage
trade to replace their vehicles
and we're still waiting for a decision
on that i think that
the feeling is that you know the hope is
that we will get that approval
before we start the consultation i think
it would be very difficult to start the
consultation without that because
that you know we need to know we need to
be able to tell the trade that there
will be this funding available
to them to be able to replace their
vehicles do you think that the funding
announcement is imminent then if
this is going to start in september and
do you think if that funding
announcement
isn't made the company is delayed again
i haven't got the details of where we're
at with you know what is it imminently
expected
um i think that they are confident i
think there's been some indication from
the government they just haven't
formally
um sent that that information i was just
trying to look for the detail because
there are
there are other elements like bus you
know i think the bus
bus funding as well is still still not
being
um approved so there are a couple of
there are a couple of other areas as
well where we've not had the final
decision from the government i would you
know
i would assume that it might have to be
delayed if we didn't get that
but um cfgm seemed very confident and
that it will be approved so i don't
think they would be setting a date
otherwise
just again for those members of the
committee that weren't here last year
can you just explain very quickly what
that funding would be used
for just outline what types of things
that the hackney
drivers would be able to apply for and
and another
yeah it would allow
it would allow um it would allow um
existing drivers and vehicle owners to
either apply for um funding to replace
their vehicles um it would it could be
either a
via a grant um
trying to let me see if we can find the
figures but either by a
by way of a grant or um to pay off
finance so um it wasn't obviously the
full
cost of a replacement vehicle it would
be a proportion of the cost of the
vehicle
um from memory um you can find the
figures
i think private for a private hire
vehicle the
proposal is that they would get two and
a half thousand pounds
to the cost or a replacement vehicle and
for a happy carriage i think it was
around ten thousand pounds obviously a
hackney carriage is very very expensive
um a new electric acne carriage is
something like
65 000 pounds so
it is not going to it might not be
enough to obviously as an incentive to
um to buy a new one duran the other
thing that has changed since the last
consultation was around
um wheelchair accessibility they
so if hackney's now been removed from
the first
stage of the clean air plan where yeah
just to clarify that the change yeah so
that
i've got the road map if that helps um
just to
so the members know why doesn't
so the consultation starts in up in
october um
on the on the clean airplane and mls
and obviously our policy as well with
the intention that
most of those proposals will come into
effect and affect
all new to licensed vehicles and drivers
from april 2021 then the clean air zone
is proposed to be introduced from 2022
[Music]
and um and then the mls you know the
proposals that um
all these policies around age and
emissions would
affect all licensed vehicles from 2023
now from the start of the
um so there'll be a transition period
from when the
the charging zone comes in in 2022 to
23 and during that period also
vehicles which are wheelchair accessible
would be exempt from the charging
the charge so that's all our hackney
carriages for instance that
are wheelchair accessible wouldn't have
to pay the charge
until 2023 and then they wouldn't have
to pay the charge if they were then
compliant
um after that date so if they um met the
missions and age standard they then
would also wouldn't have to pay the
charge
um so there is that um transition period
for
wheelchair accessible vehicles where
they would be exempt
thank you that's definitely up to
questions if anybody's got a question
that's chair yeah yeah councillor
brotherton and then councillor bot
thanks the chair don't understand you
just ask me
understood you to say these are minimum
standards across greater manchester and
individual authorities
if you wish could have slightly higher
yeah
well we'll still end up possibly then
with a situation where
manchester taxi will be different than
this traffic taxi and so on
was it not possible across greater
manchester to agree
a fixed level not just at a minimum but
a certain standard that we all stuck by
so
if somebody got an attack say it was the
same but wherever
you know the same level of service the
same level of security
across the whole of greater manchester
when you go to london and get in a taxi
you don't know what borrower you're in
do you just it's just a london taxi
let's go to manchester depends where
they get well they might get wolverine
but basically it's either a manchester
or a trafford or a sulphur taxi or wall
one of the other boroughs i just wonder
was it not just impossible to
get agreement to prosper in manchester i
think what you have to understand
is that there are ten authorities all
coming
from a different position
so some authorities had very high
standards
in certain areas others less so
so um to get everybody up to that really
high standard
which is what we want to achieve
eventually would have been would have
been
i think very difficult it may have taken
a lot longer
so by doing it this way so that we bring
um those with perhaps lesser standard in
certain areas up to
what we consider to be a reasonable
standard um
those who have a higher standard still
can keep that higher standard we're not
asking them to bring that standard down
but that's it's just kind of like a
first stage
because it has taken a long long time
for local authorities
to get to this position where they could
actually agree
a set of standards a minimum study we
would all agree to
um because i've i've been in licensing
in
um for 20 years and we've all we've
talked about it
in all that time trying to achieve this
so i'm working on this particular
project for the last
three years so um i think we all
recognized that it was going to be a big
ask for some authorities because you
know
particularly for instance those
authorities say that don't have
age standards at the moment or emission
standards
to bring them up to you know it's going
to be a big ask for their trade
to actually comply so
we just think this is the first step in
achieving
um our ultimate aim that we would have
um
yeah it's all the same standard yeah
that's fair enough at least now people
got a sort of
safety net up there's a basic level of
service that people can
expect from security but and from my
conversations with my colleagues you
know they're
we're not that disparate in lots of
areas you know
we are we are very similar in lots of
areas and this is just
we've just even that out there's might
be just one or two areas where
um some authorities have to have a
really high standard
um and i think it's slightly out of step
with everybody else but we might want to
achieve
we might want to go to that standard
ultimately
um once we've got um the trade um
familiar with and used to the minimum
standards
yeah thanks thank you councillor bob
yeah thank you
uh i mean just on that point i think
it's probably reasonable to assume that
uh with the sort of politically
homogenous
greater manchester it's not going to be
that difficult to try and come to some
kind of basic minimum standard
but the point uh i just wanted to make
here
was the you know you got the
consultation
what difference what significant
difference is there much between
what uh the trafford is looking at in
terms of their consulting what within
theirs
and the difference between that and the
minimum standard is likely to be in the
uh
the wider one because if not you know
are we having a local consultation
is it not just duplication then in a way
from the wider uh minimum standard one
are the other brothers doing similar
local consultations and then the wider
consultation which is the
minimum standard one uh can you just
explain that please
i'm not aware see i think we perhaps in
advance of other
authorities because um what we decided
to do
some time ago was try to bring all our
policies which were all over the place
really we had decisions made in
committee reports there were things in
my head
there were things in files you know
there were things on the website
what we wanted to do was to bring all of
those policies that we
knew had been agreed but weren't in one
place into one document
um and it's a recommendation which is
made by the um
part for transport that local
authorities should have a policy
taxi policy document where all our their
procedures and
policies are kept so we started working
on that already
um then obviously we started talking
about minimum standards
and um what has happened
during all those discussions is
everything that we've been agreeing
i've been putting into our policy
document
um so that because it doesn't seem to
make sense to have something different
that we would then eventually once that
we've gone through the consultation
and whatever had been approved at the
end for the minimum standards that we
then have to go and
um consult again on our local
a local policy document why not as we
were working on our own
documents at the same time try and do
the consultation
at the same time so that what
the jiggle has been to to make sure that
i got everything in
to our policy that reflected what we
want to achieve
across greater manchester there are
certain
things which are slightly higher um
certain requirements are slightly higher
than the um minimum standard that we
wanted to keep
which we've agreed we were allowed to
but overall it's very similar what we've
got in that policy our policy document
is what is going to be consulted on in
terms of the minimum standards
um to all the age requirements emission
standards
all the requirements around driver
checks and so on
uh are going to reflect um
what's in the minimum standards document
and it's interesting also because i
i put in the ret i mentioned in the
report the standards which have been
published by
the government recently which they've
been working on for very many many years
and we've been waiting on and this is
there
and it's actually gone through its
guidance which has been going through
parliament so it's not
normal guidance it's actually you know
we should have regard
to the government guidance we've had a
look at
what they're proposing only had to tweak
the minimum licensing standards slightly
to
comply because it makes sense to
um to look at you know compare what
we're proposing with the government's
proposals um or guidance um
so we didn't have to tweak it very much
to for it to comply with what the
government says
should appear in local authorities taxi
policies
um so rather than us
changing our policies after the
consultation on
mls we thought we would just um consult
at the same time
on and use also because it
because tfgm are hosting this
consultation they're going to get to a
wider audience
than possibly we could have done on a
local level so
you know being linked to it means it's
going to get a wider
um audience generally um
so the things that we that are being
consulted on in the mls
we know um we can use that data
in order to reflect our own policy as
well so we've got that double
we obviously might get feedback on our
own policy but we've also got the
feedback
on the minimum standards which appear in
our our policy so we'll get that
all that extra data on you know what
people feel about the proposals
and in terms of the uh the cost for the
consultation what's this
likely to be and how is that going to be
funded
um so um there will be a cost to the
local authority
for the consultation um
it will be shared across all ten
authorities um we are
because tfgm we're talking about the
local one yeah
well the local one we'll just i'm
obviously um we'll be using our own
website we'll be emailing
um you know stakeholders it's very much
going to be
general public and the trade really
they're the main and perhaps
disabled groups and people who who would
be impacted
who use taxis um regularly
so that's that's not really a huge cost
to us locally
there will be a cost over for the um the
minimum standards
and because that's going to be a larger
project
and involving consul consultants who
will be doing
all the analysis for the 10 authorities
on the
on the feedback
unfortunately the funding that um is
available is for things like the
replacement vehicles and so on it's
not for or from that patient on so we
so we will have to share the cost of
that consultation
um across gm waiting for that we're just
waiting for the figures
um on what that will be i think one of
the things that is very important to
know
in terms of the the local um the local
policy document is that as durant said
earlier there's never been
a full policy document and for and that
was quite surprising to us when we came
into control that there was there wasn't
that document didn't exist
um and therefore i think when we make
decisions at committee it's very
important that we
are making very very consistent
decisions and therefore it's always been
a priority
for us to get that policy document
through which is why we would have done
it a year ago
if obviously everything had happened in
the right way with the minimum standards
of that at that point
but then we were very surprised that
when um that when i came into this role
and our lead executive councillor came
into this role that that work
had never had never had never happened
and our ability to not be challenged
in court and to make good quality
consistent decisions
means we're now in a better position to
do that so
i think times have changed as well don't
forget you know i mean in terms of
emissions
i think i think actually my view is very
much that i was very very surprised that
that document didn't didn't exist and
now we've done the work that means that
that document doesn't exist
has anybody got any of the any other
points or any other questions they want
to
right cast the german yeah can i just
ask joanne you mentioned the uh this
charge and the exemptions such as the
uh wheelchair access can you just
clarify what
what this charge is for and how much it
is
um okay so um this is linked to the
clean
air plan so um the government have said
that we have to
reduce emissions in great in certain
areas in greater manchester
um i've just got some details on that
so um just to recap so
air pollution is linked to a range of
very serious health conditions including
cancer etc
and heart disease and stroke government
has directed greater manchester
to um reduced nitrogen dioxide levels
to within legal limits as soon as
possible and what britain's master has
decided to do
to tackle it is um to introduce a
charging zone
so vehicles going into that charging
zone which
don't meet certain emission standards um
will be charged so it's a way of um
changing people's behavior and by
encouraging them to buy vehicles which
are less polluting so um
you haven't haven't got the details of
the actual boundary yet that still has
got to be finalized
um i think it might include up to
say you know where the motorway is in
trafford then 60
if you're going to chester road so if
you enter that
zone and your um your vehicle
um doesn't meet the emission standards
then you'd be charged
daily a daily charge for it for
um certain vehicles um so it doesn't
include
normal private vehicles
includes vehicles like taxis
white vans coaches buses and so on
lorries
uh are subject to the the charge um
for taxes it would be um seven pound
fifty a day
that'll be the charge and then uh
increasing for the different types of
vehicles like laura's
very high charge i think it's something
like a 100 pounds a day
and all the information within the
presentation that took place doesn't it
so maybe if we can recirculate those
slides
yeah sure so members members can just
refresh themselves
information that's in those in those
flags i think everything happened to
yeah all the
all the thoughtful details in in are in
those slides
and i'll just ask another one on the on
the
um the government grant for replacing a
vehicle
there's quite a gap between ten thousand
pound
grants and the sixty five thousand pound
for a new electric
acne carriage um is there any chance i
suspect not
is there any chance of persuading the
government to increase that grant
well there are a couple that there are a
couple of funding streams
for the trade and um
it's also funding under the um cleaner
plan not just um for this the mls which
is linked to the mls
and i think from memory um the total
that you could claim was around about 17
000 pounds if you went to all these
various
streams of money so you'd have to be i
mean
cfgm will be and we will be publicizing
all the
um funding streams available for the
trade
um so that they know where to go and how
much they'll be able to claim
but it's about seventeen thousand in
total if there's anything
to bridge that gap so we sort of alluded
to it there it's a little bit better
isn't it
yeah it's not i know it's it is whether
or not that would be
sufficient for somebody to yeah
remembering in order to meet the
standards
you don't have to have a brand new
vehicle
so the vehicle emissions standards are
um petrol engines to be euro 4
which is 2005 onwards and
diesel engines to be euro 6 which is
2015 onwards
so you don't have to have a brand new
vehicle um
but obviously there'll be a premium now
on vehicles
say carriages which are a few years old
a couple of years old they'll be
perhaps um a premium on those vehicles
because
you don't have to pay the full amount
but you know um they're going to be
difficult to get hold of
yeah um in the greater manchester area
possibly
and obviously at this stage this is a
consultation isn't it so tfgm and the
local authorities will be
listening to what comes out of that
consultation and seeing what happens
from there
exactly this isn't this is these are
just proposals at the moment there's
nothing been decided
um we will see what the consultation
brings
any of the comments or anything
counselor
i'm just wondering if it's uh if given
that we'll be
obviously having to approve um this at
some point when it when it goes through
will it be worth us
having representation from some people
in the business
and hearing from them within this
committee so that we can actually hear
what it's like from the point of view of
the taxi drivers themselves rather than
just reading about
reports and the consultation on the
papers
that you provide to me after the
consultation
counselor yeah we'll become presumably
where after that point we'll then have
to approve
yeah oh i mean presumably we're not part
as members of this committee we won't be
part of that consultation though i'm
sure we'll be able to read the findings
of the consultation
you'll certainly um obviously copied
into the
the links to the consultation certainly
can take part in it
um it it's not for the committee
this committee to just to approve the
um it will go to full council eventually
but certainly we will be bringing it
back to you after the consultation so
you can see the
feedback that we've had what we will be
proposing
um to full council and asking if you
would want to recommend that to full
council
and at that stage i don't see why we
certainly could
invite members of the trade to come
along and talk to you
about um about what
you know their feelings on the proposals
and how it might impact on them
um so it might be an opportunity for
us to um to look at whether we want to
you know you want to
propose something different to the um to
just full council the intention
obviously around the minimum standards
we've done a lot of work before we've
got to this stage
to get sign up from local authorities
um to agree to this minimum standard
certainly
and so um it would it you know there'd
be a lot of pressure for us to to to
obviously
yeah sure if you know to agree to
um i think about have an agreed approach
across greater manchester at least
whatever that is uh that we're all
agreeing to the same thing
true we have had members of the trade
often come to committee
i wonder whether or not if when we get
to that point to sign off that they will
they will come up so the representatives
of both hackney and the private high-end
trade have
regularly attended committee where
there's been issues that directly affect
them policy-wise
so i have no doubt that they would um
they would
very much wish to wish to do that as and
when that that's appropriate for them to
for them to do
and we've met with them separately we've
met we've met with the trade separately
on a couple of occasions when we first
launched this last last year
as well so um there has been quite
significant engagement of which i have
no doubt there probably would have been
more
if we hadn't been in the position that
we were in
they've also had an opportunity to feed
in at greater manchester level
as well councillor welton's right i was
just going to say i mean if we do have a
couple of very quiet months is it worth
i mean just in terms of the general
working of the committee and our own
knowledge
um is it worth actually having uh you
know inviting a couple of members of the
year yeah i'll talk to you councillor
welton i'll give you a ring
and talk to you about
[Laughter]
at this stage no that's fine then we can
note that
that report thank you thank you no
urgent business
no check um we've nothing um
confidential to discuss this evening
so um bring this this meeting to a close
and then we have a further meeting
scheduled for mid-october
and we'll see whether or not we need
that meeting a little bit a little bit
closer to the time but thank you
all for attending this evening thanks
very much thank you
thank you thank you michael just stay
there a minute just stay there